did you know that there was a dua to cure anxiety mentioning the quran as well
check the description for the full dua the prophet salallahu said as part of this
new
oh allah in other words you're asking him to make the quran central a light for
your heart any cure for your anxiety a cure for every problem a relief for your
difficulty take advantage of this powerful dua think about it from beginning to end write it
down repeat it recite it memorize it and it's important in fact to memorize it and
teach it to others as the prophet salallahu advised we ask allah to make the quran
the life of our hearts the light of our chest a departure for all of our
sorrows and a release for all of our anxiety
assalamu alaikum thank you for watching our series if you want to continue learning and benefiting
has a large collection of free ebooks and resources you can download the meta website at
melrose.org
forward slash
gifts